How did you come today?
I came by train,
and besides I want to go to Europe by train.
So okay,
did you come by train today?
Of course,
now I'm at World Impact Semite,
1 exhibition dedicated to ecological transition
in which several public figures participate and
policies.
We're going to go ask them about their
ecological commitment
on a daily basis. You,
as a citizen,
how do you engage
ecologically in your daily life?
I do the individual gestures,
but I am a legislator.
And what I'd like to say is,
in fact,
responsibility,
everyone has 1,
but that the primary responsibility,
is that of our leaders,
is that of the people who are capable
to influence public policies.
First,
on the behavioral level.
I think we all have some revisions to do.
Uh. I think in
in
especially to those of my age,
because it is true that
we lived in times when we were not
attentive to these issues
environmental,
with a lot of waste.
So the frugality in the behaviors of
of consumption
uh. Is already 1,
1 important lever.
It's too easy to say,
it's uh.
The citizen's responsibility,
at least take his car,
to turn off the water when he brushes his teeth,
or something else.
When at the same time,
you have companies
as totals that continue to benefit
uh.
Funding uh.
Public date of the State
who does not pay €1 in tax and whose model
economic is based on.
The destruction of the planet.
And I chose to adopt,
uh to respect actually,
uh.
The circle effect gas emissions we should,
uh respect to be at 2°C.
I pay attention to what I eat,
to buy local.
These are personal choices,
uh,
that I can do because
I have the standard of living that allows me to do so.
And that's because I know my standard of living
that I know I can't impose it,
uh.
To the middle and working classes.